en un viaje que Putin quiere presentar
como la prueba de que no está
completamente aislado internacionalmente
que todavía tiene socios poderosos a
pesar de las crecientes sanciones
internacionales por culpa de la invasión
de Ucrania que empezó hace un año sillín
llega a Rusia además con un plan de paz
bajo el bajo brazo 12 puntos para poner
fin de manera negociada a un conflicto
en Ucrania que china se ha resistido a
condenar pero que no está interesada al
parecer en su prolongación y mucho menos
en una escalada que afecte a los
mercados mundiales la intención de ambos
lados en esta Cumbre ruso china es
profundizar Los acuerdos en un contexto
en el que Estados Unidos cada vez
desconfía más de estas dos potencias y
de su papel
económico comercial y también militar en
el mundo